was ich mich immer gefragt habe der
Pfeil auf dem Logo wo zeigt er
eigentlich in den Ausländern wo es nach
draußen geht der zeigt nach oben
sie wollen dass sich das jetzt mache
[Musik]
wo die
kiepenfelder stehen auf
da ist meine
heimatschnecken
burgerland die afd-wahl-party direkt an
der ostdeutschen Küstenlinie direkt
davor ein afd-segelschiff das nur ein
Zweck hat die syrischen flüchtlingsbote
abzufangen
Herr poggenburg ich habe ich habe die
Idee für ein total verrücktes Experiment
erzählen Sie mal wie wäre es wenn Sie
jetzt einfach mal
mitregieren haben wir gar kein Appetit
drauf sind doch nicht feige oder sind
wir nicht aber wir sind vernünftig
das heißt das wir wollen uns ganz
einfach von keiner CDU von keiner
anderen Partei korrumpieren lassen ich
finde das wäre Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
ist dann guter Ort für das Experiment
dass die AFD regiert weil hier kann man
ja praktisch nichts mehr kaputt machen
nichts relevant sind die Atombomben
wurden ja auch in der Wüste von Nevada
getestet sie sind Spitzenkandidat für
Berlin wenn die AFD in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern mit 3%
Ausländeranteil gut 21% holt dann müssen
sie ja in Berlin 240 Prozent holen dann
wissen Sie ja ganz sicher wenn man 240%
holen könnte wäre schön ja aber sie
wissen ja dass nur 100% gibt oder
[Gelächter]
in Berlin in die Schule gegangen oder
Nein in Nordrhein-Westfalen Alter ist
genau so schlimm war mein Sohn auch mal
in der Schule da war die Bildung auch
nicht sehr gut okay ja ja
sehr gut denke ich ja sie haben ja
offensichtlich ein sehr guten Geschmack
warum sind Sie bei der AFD
ja und ich finde das ist eine Zeit ist
dass die Propagandisten an der
bundesnation ein denksel erhalten aber
ich dachte das sind sie die
Propagandisten
kann es sein dass die AFD auch so ein
bisschen entzaubert wird wenn sie an der
Macht ist weil die Leute dann merken es
ändert sich ja gar nicht weil mit
pokerverbot bleibt man ja auch
arbeitslos nee wird sie eben nicht weil
die AFD eben erst an die Macht an die
Regierung geht wenn sie so weit ist also
nie doch wenn sie soweit ist das wird
kommen also nie und dadurch wird sie
auch nicht entzaubert was mich immer
gefragt habe der Pfeil auf dem Logo wo
zeigt er eigentlich in den Ausländern wo
es nach draußen geht der zeigt nach oben
zeigen sie wollen dass ich das jetzt
mache werden sie so lieb
schade wäre ein schönes Bild gewesen
hallo Sie sind ja Bundessprecher für die
homosexuell in der AFD das heißt sie
wissen ja wie das ist für die Leute vom
anderen Ufer jetzt kommen die alle aus
Afrika und sie schicken die weg
oh
also das ist jetzt schade oder ja jetzt
sagen wir Nein zu den Afrikaner was vom
anderen Ufer kommen Prinzip ist aber
auch müssen sie da nicht ein bisschen
mehr Mitleid haben bringen Sie da Pipi
in die Augen
habe ich
habe jetzt leider kein Taschentuch und
sie haben kein Mitleid
nein nein
Herr Ministerpräsident sie waren ja mal
morgenmoderator bei Antenne macpom
würden Sie für uns eine kleine Station
ID einsprechen hallo mein Name ist sie
sehen die heute schon mit den besten
Witzen der 80er 90er Jahre
ja kein Problem ja hallo
mein Name ist
mein Name ist jetzt ihr Name
[Musik]
hallo Leute Ich bin's der heute-show
meme Ersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
Scheiß und liegt
memes wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
Kanal
was zur Hölle ist ein meme er
[Musik]